you got picked up you're making these
episodes that's a lot of work it's a lot
of work you're also a very successful
stand-up and you're a single dad how do
you manage well I will that in I'm
recently a single debt I haven't always
been a single dad you're not born a
single dad I suppose some people are
yeah but I broke up with my ex we still
get along everything's fine but I used
to parent I used to think I was
parenting like when there was a two of
us I'd say things like how you going
Hank to my son yeah what are you playing
with and then I'd lay down and now I
have him every two days two days on two
days off and I actually have to parent
like I have to feed him like I have to
wash him and stop I don't actually wash
him as much as you think because I
figure he'll be with his mom in two days
and she can wash him then as long as
he's on that cycle but the other the
other day I fed him chicken I cooked up
some cheese you cooked chicken that's a
that's a good dad yeah daddy likes
chicken so I made him some chicken and
then I fed him the chicken and I ate
some of the chicken as well and then
like we went to bed he went to bed at
like 9:00 I went to bed at like 11 or
something and about 11 o'clock he wakes
up just screaming dad died and he's
holding his abdomen because I gave him
food poisoning you see and and he's just
and he's like he's crying he's like I've
never felt so much pain died and so he
goes up to the toilet I just watch him
he's [ __ ] himself and it's weird
it's weird when you're four because you
think well this is me now he just
thought he's gonna spend the rest of his
life on a toilet
oh he just thought he was dying Wow I
said you gotta be fine mate you gonna be
fine I gave him in a mo diem and over
tums to settle his stomach and a baby
tylenol hey you're overdoing it with the
bad just take it easy
I I let him come and sleep in me being a
gamer catalyser you're gonna be alright
mate anyway an hour about two hours
later I wake up and I start [ __ ]
myself but my sister and I'm sitting on
the toilet and I'm just [ __ ] myself
I'm like crying and then he he walks in
holding his teddy in his hairs or floppy
and he's in his pajamas and he looks at
me he goes we had a tough night didn't
we
[Applause]
you